I've got this matrix a here it's a 2x3
matrix and just as a bit of review let's
figure out its null space in its column
space so the null space of a it's the
set of all vectors X that are member of
let's see we have three columns here so
a member of r3 such that a times the
vector are going to be equal to the zero
vector so we could just set this up let
me just just so we just need to figure
out all of the X's that satisfy this in
r3 so we take our matrix a 2 - 1 - 3 - 4
- 6 multiply them times some arbitrary
vector in r3 here so you get X 1 X 2 X 3
and you set them equal to the zero
vector it's going to be the zero vector
in r2 because we have two rows here you
multiply two by three matrix times a
vector in r3 you're going to get a 2 by
1 vector or 2 by 1 matrix so you're
gonna get the 0 vector in r3 and to
solve what is essentially a system of
equations you get 2 X 1 minus X 2 minus
3 X 3 is equal to 0 and so on and so
forth we can just set up an Augmented
matrix so we can just set up this
Augmented matrix right here 2 - 1 - 3 -
4 - 6 and then augment it with what
we're trying to set it equal to to solve
the system and you know we're going to
put up we're going to perform a bunch of
row operations here to put this in
reduced row echelon form and they're not
going to change this the right-hand side
of this augmented matrix and that's
essentially the argument as to why the
null space of the reduced row echelon
form of a is the same thing as the null
space of a but anyway that's just a bit
of review so let's perform some row
operations to solve this a little bit
better so the first thing I might want
to do is divide let's divide the first
row by 2 so if I divide the first row by
2 I get a 1 minus 1/2 minus 3 1/2 and
then of course 0 divided by 2 is 0 and
let's just divide let's divide this row
right here let's just divide it by I
don't know list of
I did just to simplify things let's
divide it by four so I'm provide I'm
doing two row operations in one step but
you can do that I could have done it in
two separate steps so we if we divide it
by 4 this becomes minus 1 1/2 and then
you get what 3 halves and then you get
zero and now let's keep my first row the
same I'm going to keep my first row the
same it's 1 minus 1/2 minus three-halves
and of course the 0 is the right-hand
side and let's replace my second row
with my second row plus my first row so
these are just linear operations on
these guys so negative 1 plus 1 is 0 1/2
plus minus 1/2 is 0 three-halves plus
minus three-halves is 0 and of course 0
plus 0 is 0 so what are we left with
we're left with this right here or this
is another way of saying this is another
way of saying that X 1 let me write it
this way X 1 X 1 is you could I guess
the easiest way to think about it is
you're multiplying the reduced row
echelon form of a now 1 minus 1/2 minus
3 halves you have a bunch of zeros here
times X 1 X 2 X 3 is equal to the r20
vector this is another interpretation of
this augmented matrix so this is just
saying this is useless this is saying
zero times ad plus zero times a plus
zero times that is equal to zero so it's
giving us no information but this first
this first row tells us that we switch
colors 1 times X 1 X 1 minus 1/2 times X
2 minus 1/2 times X 2 minus three-halves
three-halves times X 3 is equal to 0 all
of the vectors whose components satisfy
this are in my null space so I want to
write a little bit differently I could
write it as X 1 is equal to 1/2 X 2 plus
3 halves X 3 or if I wanted to write my
solution set in vector form I could
write that my well my
null space is going to be the set of all
the vectors x1 x2 x3
let's satisfy these conditions that are
equal to what well x2 and x3 are free
variables they're associated with the
non pivot entries or the non-pivot
columns in our reduced row echelon form
that is a pivot column that is a pivot
column right there so what are what is
going to I could set so let me write it
this way it's going to be x2 times
something plus x3 times something all
right those are my two free variables
and we have here X 1 is 1/2 X to 1/2
times x2 plus three-halves times x3
three-halves times x3 x2 is just going
to be x 2 times 1 plus 0 times x3 x3 is
going to be 0 times x2 plus 1 times x3
so our null space our null space these
can be any real numbers right here right
there free variables so our null space
is essentially all of the linear
combinations of this guy and that guy or
another way to write it the null space
of a the null space of a is equal to the
span which is the same thing as all the
linear combinations of the span of 1
half 1 0 notice these are vectors in r3
and that makes sense because the null
space is going to be a set of vectors in
r3 so it's a span of that and that right
there and that right there so 3 halves 0
and 1 just like that and what is the
column what is the column space of our
original matrix a so the column space
the column space of a is equal to just
all of the linear the subspace created
by all of the linear combinations of
these guys or essentially the span of
the column vectors is equal to the span
of 2 minus 4 minus 1 2 minus 3
six these are all each separate vectors
so it's the span of these three vectors
now these guys might not be linearly
independent and actually when you put
this guy in reduced row-echelon form you
know that the basis vectors for this are
the vectors that are associated with our
pivot column so we have one pivot column
here it's our first column so we could
say that we could use this as a basis
vector and it makes sense because this
guy right here is minus 2 times the sky
this guy right here is what minus
three-halves times that guy so these two
guys can definitely be represented as
linear combinations of that guy so it's
equal to the span the span of just of
just the vector 2 minus 4 so if you were
to ask me and this is this is the basis
for our column space so if you want to
know the rank and this is all a bit of
review the rank of a is equal to the
number of vectors in our basis for our
column space so it's going to be equal
to 1 now everything I just did is a bit
of review but with the last couple of
videos we've been dealing with
transposes so let's actually figure out
the same ideas for the transpose of a
for the transpose of a so a transpose a
transpose looks like this a transpose is
equal to the vector 2 minus 1 or the
matrix 2 minus 1 minus 3 is the first
column right there and then the second
column is going to be minus 4 2 & 6 that
is our transpose so let's figure out the
null space and the column space of our
transpose of our transpose so let's just
do the let's just well let me put this
in reduced row echelon form so we can
get the null space let me get the null
space of this guy so we could do the
exact same exercise we could do the
exact same X let me write it this way
the null space of a transpose a
transpose is a 3 by 2 matrix so it's
equal to
all of the vectors X that are members of
r2 that are members of r2 not r3 anymore
because now we're taking the transpose
is null space such that a transpose
times our vectors are equal to the zero
vector in r3 is equal to the zero vector
in r3 and we can do that the same exact
way we did before we set up an Augmented
matrix we could we could just put it in
reduced row echelon form and set them
all equal to zero so let's just do that
there so if we let me just put it in
reduced row echelon form so let me let
me divide my first row by two let's
divide the first row by two just gonna
put in reduced row echelon form the
first row divided by 2 is 1 minus 2 and
then the second row let me divide it
let me just I'll just keep it the same
so minus minus 1/2 and then this last
row let me divide it by 3 so it becomes
minus 1 and 2 and now let me keep my
first row the same 1 minus 2 and now let
me replace my second row with my second
row plus my first row so minus 1 plus 1
0 2 plus minus 2 is 0 you get some
zeroes I'm gonna do the same thing with
the third row replace it with it plus
the first row once again you're going to
get some zeroes so this is the reduced
row echelon form of a transpose so this
is the reduced row echelon form of a
transpose and it's null space is the
same as a transpose is null space so we
could set we could say to find this null
space we can find all of the solutions
to this equation times the vectors x1
and x2 is equal to 0 0 & 0
these aren't vectors these are just
entries right here 0 0 0 so these two
lines give us no information but this
first one does so we get 1 times x1 and
notice this is the pivot column right
here it's associated so x1 is going to
be a pivot variable this is a x2 will be
a free variable
and just to be clear that the first
column is our pivot column so if we go
back to a transpose it's this first
column here that is associated with the
pivot column so when we talk about its
column space this by itself will span
the column space this is all a review
what we did before we're just applying
it to the transpose let's go back to our
null space so this tells us that 1 times
X 1 so X 1 minus 2 times X 2 minus 2
times X 2 is equal to is equal to 0 or
we could say that X 1 is equal to 2
times X 2 so all of the vectors in r2
that satisfy these conditions with this
entries will be in the null space of a
transpose let me write it this way let
me write it this way if I want to do it
so the null space the null space of a is
going to be the set of all the vectors
let me write it here the set of all the
vectors x1 x2 that are a member of r2
clearly such that such that x1 x2 is
going to be equal to well our free
variable is X 2 so it's X 2 times the
vector times the vector so x1 has to be
2 times x2 and obviously x2 that's a 2x2
is going to be 1 times x2 so what is
this going to be well this is all of the
linear combinations of this vector right
here of this vector right here so we
could say it's equal to the span the
span of our vector the span of our of
the vector 2 1 now that's the null space
I this was the null space of a transpose
have to be very careful there now what
is the column space the column space of
a transpose
well the column space of a transpose is
the set of all vectors spanned by the
columns of a so you could just say the
span of this column vector in this
column vector but we know when we put
into reduced row echelon form only this
column vector was associated with a with
a pivot column so this by itself this
guys the linear combination of this guy
if you multiply this if you multiply him
by minus two you get that guy right
there so it's consistent with everything
we've learned so it equals the span it
equals the span of just of just this guy
right here of just the vector of just
the vector 2 minus 1 and minus 3 now
that's just a nice neat exercise that we
did you know notice that your span here
it's in r3 but it's just going to be a
line in r3 and we can maybe on the next
video I'll do a more graphical
representation of it but I did this
whole exercise is to introduce you to
the ideas of the null space of your
transpose and the column space of your
transpose think about what the column
space of your transpose is it's the it's
the subspace spanned by that vector I'm
sorry
spanned by this vector and that vector
and it turns out that this guy is a
multiple of that guy so we could say
just by that guy but these were the rows
of our original of our original matrix a
so we could we could also view this as
the span of the row vectors of the row
vectors of our original guy right this
is that column that is the basis for the
column span of the R transpose matrix
and of course this guy was a linear
combination of that so we can also view
the column span of our transpose matrix
it's equivalent to the subspace spanned
by these rows or we could call that the
row space of a so let me write that down
so the column space of a transpose and
this is just general let me write this
generally it doesn't just apply to this
example so the column space of any of
the transpose of any matrix this is
called the row the row space the row
space of a it's a very natural name
because if a is got a bunch of rows we
could call them the transpose of some
vectors so that's the first row you got
the second row all the way to maybe
the M throw the M throw just like that
these are vector transpose this they're
really just rows if you imagine the
space that's spanned by these vectors by
the different rows that's essentially
the column space of the transpose so
when you transpose it each of these guys
become columns so that's what the row
space is now the null space the null
space of our transpose let's write it
like this it was all of the vectors X
that satisfied this equation equals
equals the zero vector right there
now what happens what happens if we take
the transpose of both sides of this
equation so if we take the transpose of
both sides of that equation well we've
learned from our transpose properties
this is equal to the reverse product of
each of those transposes so this is
going to be equal to this is a vector
the vector X transpose so now it's going
to become if this is a column vector
before now it's going to become a row
vector and then times a transpose
transpose and that's going to be equal
to the transpose of the zero vector or
we could just write this as let's write
it like this we could write this as some
matrix well let me just write it like
this some column vector X time what's
the transpose of a transpose well that's
just equal to a so you take the
transpose of this of this column vector
you now get a row vector you could view
it as a matrix if you want it's you know
if this was a member of RN this is now
going to be an N by what this is an N by
or 1 by n matrix if this was and a
member of RN and when we and now it's
essentially we kind of switch the orders
and we multiply it times the transpose
of the transpose we just get the matrix
a and we set that equal to the transpose
of the zero vector now this is
interesting we now have it in terms of
our original matrix a now what did the
null space of our matrix a look
the null-space where all of the vectors
exit satisfied this equation is equal to
zero so the X was on the right this is
so the null spaces all the X's that
satisfy this the null space of our
transpose is all of the X's that satisfy
this equation and this is also called so
this is so let me say the set of all of
the X's that such that a transpose times
X is equal to 0 that is the null space
of a transpose that is equal to the null
null space of a transpose or we could
also write this as the set of all of the
X's such that the transpose of our x
times a is equal to the transpose of the
0 vector and we have another name for
this this is called the left null space
the left null space null space of a why
is it called in the left null space
because now we have X on our left and
just a regular null space you have X on
the right but now if you take the null
space of the transpose the null space of
the transpose using just our transpose
properties that's equivalent to this
transpose vector right here actually let
me write this a transpose right there
this transpose vector multiplying a from
the left-hand side so all of the X's
that satisfy this is the left null space
and it's going to be different than your
null space because it was equal to
notice your null space of a transpose
was a span of this right here this is
also the left left null space the left
null space of a now what was just a
regular null space of a the regular null
space of a was a essentially a plane in
r3 that's the null space of a the left
null space of a the left null space of a
is just a line in our two very different
things
very different things and if you go to
the if you go to the row space what is
the row space of a the row space of a is
a line in r3 the row space of a is a
line in R
three well what is the column space of a
a column space of a right here whereas I
have it it was a well this is the only
linear and literally independent vector
it was essentially a line in r2 so
they're all very different things and
we'll study a little bit more how
they're all related now there's one
thing I want to relate to you we figured
out that the rank of this vector right
here is one right because when you put
it when you put it in reduced row
echelon form
there was one pivot there was one pivot
column and the the basis vectors are
those associated with that pivot column
and if you count your basis vectors
that's your dimension of your space so
the dimension of your column space is
one and that's the same thing as your
rank now what is the rank of a transpose
the rank of a transpose in the example
when you put it in reduced row echelon
form you got one linearly independent
column vector so the basis for our
column space was also equal to one and
in general that's always going to be the
case that's always going to be the case
that the rank of a which is the
dimension of its column space is equal
to the rank of a transpose and if you
think about it it makes a lot of sense
to figure out the rank of a you
essentially figure out how many to
figure out the rank of a you essentially
just have to figure out how many pivot
columns they have or another way to say
it is how many pivot entries they have
now to figure out when you when you
figure out the row space when you figure
out the column space of when you want to
find the rank of your of your transpose
vector you're essentially just saying
and I know this is maybe getting a
little bit confusing but when you want
the rank of your transpose vector you're
saying which how many of these columns
are linearly independent or which of
these are linearly independent
right and that's the same question as
saying how many of your rows up here are
linearly independent if you want to know
how many columns and your transpose are
linearly independent that's equivalent
to asking how many rows
your original matrix are linearly
independent and when you put this matrix
in reduced row echelon form everything
in reduced row echelon form are just row
operation so just linear combinations of
these things up here or you could go
vice versa everything up here is just
linear combinations of your matrix in
reduced row echelon form so if you only
have one pivot entry if you only have
one pivot entry then this guy right here
by himself or one pivot row that guy by
himself can represent a basis can
represent a basis for your row space or
all of your rows can be represented by a
linear combination of your pivot rows
and because of that you just count that
you say okay there's one in this case so
the dimension of my row space is one and
that's the same thing as the dimension
of the columns of my column spaces
transpose I know it's all of my
transpose is column space I know it's
getting all confusing insulating the day
for me as well so that's hopefully it
will convince you that the rank of our
transpose is the same as the rank of our
original matrix